[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui à chloé verlhac
pour son livre si tu meurs je te tue aux
éditions plon bonjour recueillir lac
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes auteur éditrice et se livrera
contre votre histoire d'amour avec le
grand dessinateur tignes où s'inquiétait
votre mari qui était assassiné je le
rappelle tragiquement le 7 janvier 2015
en compagnie de sept de ses camarades de
charlie hebdo
en tout 12 personnes avaient péri dans
cette attaque islamiste alors évidemment
l'avoir perdue est une douleur
épouvantable que vous avez réussi à
mettre en mots c'est un livre très
émouvant qui arrache des larmes bien
entendu et vous raconter ce drame mais
aussi ses suites
votre survie en tant que femme en tant
que maman car vous êtes mère de deux des
enfants de tignes où c'est donc vous
témoigner de ses tribulations à la
situer la suite de cet horrible attentat
c'est un livre poignant mais c'est aussi
heureusement un récit de résilience un
récit de libération de retour à une vie
à votre vie vous semblez avoir écrit
d'ailleurs autant pour thynnus que pour
vous finalement quels ont été les
bienfaits de l'écriture de ce livre je
crois le principal bien fait c'est que
ça apaiser ma colère parce que malgré
tout j'étais une femme en colère même si
je n'avais pas envie de me laisser
déborder par cette colère il y avait
évidemment de la colère et le fait de ne
pas avoir pu dire au revoir à tignes où
c'était quelque chose de terrible et le
livre a permis ça et je suis maintenant
une femme apaisé voilà un mois sur ce
titre si tu meurs je te tue à part moi
vous le disait beaucoup at il usé mais
pourquoi ce que thynnus avait 21 ans de
plus que moi à l'arrivée est très jeune
mais il avait quand même 21 ans de plus
que moi
et de temps en temps ça le
salle angoisse est donc il me disait tu
sais le jour où je serai plus là
faudrait que tu refasses d'avis il
disait des très jolies choses mais que
je n'avais absolument pas envie
d'entendre
et donc je couper court à la
conversation lui disant de toute façon
je te préviens si tu meurs je te tue
voilà on l'a dans ce livre on vous
découvre extrêmement proche de votre
mari un couple très fusionnelle avec une
très grande connivence aussi bien
intellectuelle que dans votre vie intime
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler de
cette connexion depuis votre première
rencontre en 96 jusqu'à la
concrétisation si j'ose dire le premier
baiser en 2002 parlez parlez moi de 7,7
ce lien très fort mais c'est une jolie
histoire - tin oo je les rencontre et
j'avais 18 ans et
je les croisais tous les ans pendant six
ans et c'est drôle parce que mon nom de
famille de jeune fille commence par un z
et comme je déménageais tout le temps il
est objet de rayer il me disait mais tu
vois le bordel que tu fous dans mon
carnet parce que tous les ans il y
régnait mon adresse et puis
2002 on s'est vus et je sais pas il ya
eu quelque chose de l'ordre du voilà de
l'électricité et puis et puis et puis on
s'est plus quittés il ya eu quelque
chose de très il fallait qu'on se
rencontre avec tinos en fait il fallait
que on aime on avait forcément quelque
chose à vivre
on était surtout cette sensation que si
on nous posait n'importe où du moment
qu'on était tous les deux on pouvait
être partout il pouvait se passer
n'importe quoi tant qu'on était ensemble
ça se passait bien et surtout il me
faisait énormément rire mais je le
faisais beaucoup rire aussi
et on partageait beaucoup ça il le
partage des quelques valeurs par exemple
si nous c'était un journaliste politique
malgré tout c'était quelqu'un
d'extrêmement engagé après c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais pris de carte
nulle part parce qu'ils ne m'aiment pas
la fcpe même pas chez les parents
d'élèves
ce qui ne voulait pas qu'on le qu'on le
taxe de 2
de quoi que ce soit il voulait se sentir
relativement libre après on a toujours
voilà partager on était des fervents
défenseurs de la laïcité des valeurs
républicaines et si vous savez un vrai
respect du monde du travail
tu es quelqu'un qui avait pas oublié
d'où il venait ni qui il était continuer
à s'intéresser au travail des jeunes
dessinateurs en disant moi si j'en suis
là c'est parce que il y en a d'autres
qui ont regardé mon travail était
quelqu'un de très de très humble et en
même temps de très fermes sur ce qu'il
avait à défendre
charlie hebdo était déjà menacé avant
les intérêts avant les attentats est ce
que vous craignez une attaque évidemment
pas de cette ampleur mais ce que vous
viviez un peu dans la peur avec ti
mousse à l'époque alors on ne vivait pas
dans la peur
c'est j'ai regardé hier une petite vidéo
qui a été tournée par sa fille aînée
quand elle était étudiante où elle est
venue l'interviewer au journal et à lui
poser cette question
c'était en avril 2014 elle visait ce que
vous avez peur avec les menaces et ils
nous disaient mais en fait au quotidien
bien sûr on a reçu des menaces de mort
tout ça mais on n'y pense pas parce que
nous on fait notre métier et que si en
faisant un dessin on devait se dire oh
là là est ce que ça ça va énerver que et
ben en fait on n'y pense pas il a eu
cette réponse là maintenant je suis pas
sûr que ce soit tout à fait vrai parce
que ce que je raconte dans le livre
intime you say party au danemark en
novembre 2014
quand il est rentré il était très
content parce qu'ils avaient très bien
mangé que les gens étaient très gentils
mais il a signé des galets sur lesquels
il avait dessiné au dos en me disant on
sait jamais donc voilà je crois que
il était extrêmement rassurant mais oui
peut-être qu'il ya malgré tout mais en
même temps ils y croyaient pas c'est à
dire que c'était des gens simples
c'était des gens simples inquiets des
menaces oui d intimidation comme brûler
les locaux oui mais un assassinat
vraiment gênant je pense que j'y croyais
pas et moi non salue un point de non
retour
cette cet acte là mais normalement dans
une démocratie
au 21e siècle on n'assassine pas des
journalistes
c'est sûr alors on apprend dans ce livre
que ti news juste avant le drame avait
eu une pensée pour les jeunes
radicaliser il avait cité cette phrase
est ce que vous êtes posé la question de
notre part de responsabilité dans le
malheur de ces jeunes pour qu'ils en
arrivent là
donc c'était un homme ouvert tolérant
pas un va-t-en-guerre vous dit
d'ailleurs que c'est un homme bien un
mec bien qu'ils ont assassiné pouvez
nous en parler
et ça c'est pas une citation c'est oui
c'est ce qui est en fait la réunion la
réunion de rédaction ce jour là portait
sur les jeunes qui partait faire le
djihad est bon ils n'étaient pas tous
d'accord dans la rédaction et certains
condamnés en dix ans il y en a marre
d'être compréhensifs
maintenant ça suffit et c'est là où
tillous voilà ramener ses vraies
questions là et sur une sur la part de
responsabilité parce que c'est quelqu'un
finalement tignes où ce qui ne jugeait
pas tim seeley mais les gens et
et ils rencontraient tout le monde avec
exactement le même sourire le même
entrain après les gens lui plus il lui
plaisait plus ou moins il n'y avait pas
de jugement de valeur
dans un premier temps et dans son
travail c'était quelqu'un de gentil qui
moussent les dessins quand ils sont durs
c'est parce que le sujet dur mais
thynnus ne condamnait pas par contre il
donnait à voir
il pointe elle et les problèmes mais
mais c'était quelqu'un avec qui qui ne
chantent i vous raconter dans ce livre
le moment du drame qui est un ko est une
horreur et alors ce qui est extrêmement
choquant c'est que vous expliquez que
vous rencontrez une série de personnes
le jour même où juste après qu'ils sont
tous le cruel et incompétents les uns
que les autres c'est assez sidérant que
ce soit des psys des soignants toutes
les personnes que vous rencontrez non
exactement enfin exactement les mots
qu'il ne faut pas comment vous expliquer
ça à ce que la france n'était pas prête
alors c'est pour ça que les bonnes
personnes étaient au rendez vous je ne
sais pas comment vous expliquez ça il ya
cinq ans après je pense qu'il ya aucune
volonté de
les gens n'étaient pas cruel il n'y a
pas de volonté de faire du mal et tout
le monde était complètement dépassé par
par l'événement d'abord par la brutalité
l'angoissent que ça a fait monter moi je
sais de ce qu'on a raconté
même si j'ai pas vu les images mais que
c'était une scène de guerre
c'était terrible là haut et que les tous
les soignants ou les forces de l'ordre
auquel on a eu affaire ont finalement
été touché en tant que forces de l'orde
professionnellement mais ils ont tous
été touché humainement et en tant que
citoyen et 7,7
ils ont pas réussi à faire la part des
choses à ce moment là et du coup ils
étaient dans l'incapacité de nous gérer
nous et je pense que c'est plutôt un
manquement que qu'une volonté en tout
cas de de mal faire vous pensez que
maintenant c'est mieux organisés pas
vraiment je parle des victimes non quand
un drame catastrophe comme celle ci
survient est ce que maintenant il y a
les bonnes personnes au bon moment pour
aider les victimes
ça je ne moi j'ai été très fâché
d'être reçu par le secrétariat d'état
aux victimes et d'être auditionnés en
fait j'ai eu l'impression d'être
consultante en attente a c'est à dire
qu'à aucun moment on nous a demandé
comment on allait mais on nous a demandé
les erreurs qu'il ne fallait pas refaire
ça a été une épreuve terrible ça alors
maintenant j'espère et je leur souhaite
d'être mieux organisé vous a également
promis beaucoup dead et de suivi vous
parlez de françois hollande qui était
président à l'époque qui vous a fait des
promesses qui n'ont pas été effective et
ce n'est pas le seul à vous avoir fait
des promesses qui n'ont pas été tenues
pouvez-vous nous en parler c'est assez
simple en fait c'est à dire que en
janvier 2015 on est reçu à l'elysée avec
les laisse donc les familles de victimes
et familles des victimes des attentats
aussi des 8 et 9 janvier et tout le
monde est bouleversé et tout le tout la
famille politique française est
bouleversée et donc ils ont envie de
nous faire des promesses ils ont envie
et à ce moment là je pense qu'ils sont
profondément sont sincères sont vraiment
vous à 10 je remets pas ça du tout en
question
sauf qu'après il ya la réglementation
après il ya la loi
après il ya les formulaires après ya les
dossiers après à l'administration et on
rentre pas dans les cases et personne ne
prend la responsabilité de changer cette
réglementation de la modifier de faire
quoi que ce soit donc pour moi c'est
depuis l'impression du livre il ya eu du
mieux
enfin césar que
mais il a fallu parce que donc
effectivement il ya eu des manquements
mais il ya eu des gens merveilleux
moi j'ai été trés accompagné par le
maire de montreuil patrice bessac par la
maire de paris anne hidalgo par
christiane taubira qui était à l'époque
garde des sceaux c'est des gens qui
m'ont beaucoup soutenu qu'ils ont
continué à me suivre et grâce à qui
aujourd'hui je pense mon dossier a été
enfin débloqué hier jacques toubon aussi
que j'ai rencontré défenseur des droits
j'ai même écrit à brigitte macron cet
été pour vous dire à quel point de
désespoir j'en étais arrivée qui m'a
répondu d'ailleurs une très jolie lettre
voilà et enfin je pense que la situation
va être un peu des blocs et parce que
enfin ils vont prendre une mesure
exceptionnelle
mais alors quel quel site quelle mesure
va être prise parce que c'est un petit
peu technique et un petit peu long mais
bon pour essayer de vous le dire très
simplement
[Musique]
tignes où ça a été déclarée victime d'un
attentat terroriste s'est inscrit par
arrêté de la garde des sceaux inscrits
au journal officiel inscrit sur son acte
de décès est donc normalement nous
devions être pris en charge par le fonds
de garantie or tignes où c'était
salariés de charlie assassiné sur son
lieu de travail donc déclarée en
accident du travail
donc je suis rentré dans la
réglementation de la cpam ou elle vous
en parlez dans votre magie pour pouvoir
s'appliquer est soumise à conditions et
donc au fait que je ne sois pas remariée
que je ne vis soit pas pâques c'est que
je n'existe en concubinage que femme en
tout un tas de choses qui est à côté de
ça on vous dit mais il faudrait vous
reconstruirez continuer votre vie c'est
celle de l'imaginable
on va faire une pause chloé vers là
qu'on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
chloé verlhac pour son livre si tu meurs
je te tue aux éditions plon
l'histoire d'amour avec ti news chloé on
lit dans votre livre ce qu'on a pu
découvrir dans la presse aussi donc vous
en parlais tout à l'heure des déboires
avec le fonds d'indemnisation des
victimes c'est à dire que vous avez dû
être évaluée avec des calculs
d'apothicaire
c'est vraiment une sorte de énorme
douleur imposé aux victimes comment vous
l'avez vécu ça j'ai pas très bien vécu
mon entretien avec le psychiatre du
fonds de garantie parce que je me
demandais s'il allait mesurer mon
chagrin la quantité de la ram que
j'allais vers sait comment voilà comment
allait-il faire pour mesurer ce chagrin
là maintenant
ils ne savent pas expliquer en fait il
ya très peu de pédagogie autour de tout
ça avec le recul je pense que c'est
nécessaire
ils sont obligés d'avoir des barèmes
parce que sinon ils ne seraient soumis
qu'à leur propre humanité leur propre
affection ou d amour des gens qui le
rencontre et c'est pas possible ce
serait pas juste des victimes on dit par
exemple que ce fonds garanti essayer de
tirer des montants à la baisse en fait
mais tout organisme payeur essaye de
tirer les montants à la baisse c'est
particulièrement choquant dans ce qu'on
sait c'est terrible c'est terrible bien
sûr mais après je moi je me suis
beaucoup apaisé par rapport à ça parce
que c'est pas la vie c'est parce qu'ils
nous c'est pour ça moi aussi que ça a
pris autant de temps c'est que
j'arrivais pas à me battre pour ça ça me
ça m'empêche ça ça m'aurait empêché de
vivre de me projeter d'être parce que ça
ça entretient la colère et le cette
espèce de sentiment de double peine qui
peut rendre qui peut rendre et ne
voulais pas de ça toujours sur le plan
de la colère on va parler de la réaction
de charlie hebdo vous et corner
évidemment le mythe quand vous parlez de
leurs réactions après les attentats et
se trouve qui ne vous ont rien versé
comme un geste parce que vous étiez
maman de deux enfants en bas âge et y
est la seule victime avec des enfants en
bas âge donc clairement il fallait
s'occuper de ses enfants autant de vous
que des enfants alors marianne par
exemple avec magazine dans lequel
thynnus dessinée et bien tout a tout de
suite fait quelque chose
charlie hebdo non pourquoi ce manque
d'empathie est ce que vous arrivez à le
comprendre je
[Musique]
je crois que dans un premier temps on a
tous il fallait tout ce qu on se relève
de ça on a tous gérés le drame comme on
a pu ce qui est ce que je n'explique pas
c'est pourquoi le temps passant rien n'a
changé et rien n'a été fait ça je suis
bien en peine de de vous l'expliquer par
contre c'est vrai que marianne a été
d'un très très joli soutien moi j'avais
besoin d'humanité à ce moment là on en
avait très peu en fait
et c'est alors heureusement il y avait
les gens et les gens du quotidien qui
ont été formidables et marianne qui nous
a surtout souhaité dans ce qu'ils ont
donné aux enfants la place qu'ils ont
donné à tignes tentante que dessinateur
parce que c'était difficile pour les
enfants de comprendre pourquoi
déjà nous on avait du mal alors c'était
très compliqué de leur expliquer mais
tout d'un coup ce journal leur dise à
quel point il manquait au journal à quel
point c'est un grand dessinateur que les
gens les uns vis dans leur maison de
campagne leur fasse des cadeaux etc
tout d'un coup les enfants étaient très
fiers et ça donnait du sens et leur papa
prenait toute sa place et c'était
quelqu'un de bien et ça ça nous a
beaucoup aidés vous parlez en parlant de
charlie hebdo vous dites que l'esprit
charlie et max ont pu les mêmes
personnes vous vous maintenez je
maintiens que la quasi totalité de ceux
qui ont remonté le titre en 92 ont été
assassinés que ceux qui ont été
assassinés étaient les politiques du
journal il était l'âme de ce journal et
oui ils ont tué charly maraux delà de
charlie hebdo vous êtes vous évoquez les
limitations toujours plus grande de la
liberté de presse qui met évidemment en
péril le dessin à le dessin satirique
est ce que pour vous les patrons presse
ou des éditeurs ont finalement cédé à la
menace intégriste ou tout simplement la
censure de l'époque
moi j'ai pas l'impression que là
que les éditeurs aient cédé à quoi que
ce soit j'ai en 4 ans et demi est dit et
11 livres de team usa 9 livres et de
calendriers perpétuels
j'ai subi aucune
censure de la part de l'éditeur on a
passé des dessins voilà tout ce j'ai
voulu passer qui sont pas tous très
consensuel dans l'écriture du livre
aucune ligne ne m'a été retiré moi j'ai
pas l'impression de subir ça après il ya
on est dans la farce et malgré tout à
l'air du temps il n'y a pas que le
dessin de presse qui subit 7 700 sur
l'a2 j'ai l'impression que de manière
générale l'art est un petit peu
attaquées est-ce que vous pensez que ce
fonds de m qui peut s'attaquer à charlie
hebdo comme à la liberté de presse
aujourd'hui est suffisamment combattu en
france
est ce qu'on la prend au sérieux cette
menace d'ailleurs je rappelle que la
tombe de volant ce qui a été dégradée en
quelques jours après le 5e anniversaire
donc cette menace se fonde n existe
toujours
alors je
voudrais pas autres passé mon rôle et me
transformer en analyste politique
mais moi j'ai participé par exemple à la
manifestation du 11 janvier
c'était exceptionnel exceptionnel de
voir comment les gens étaient capables
tout d'un coup de s'indigner de se
fédérer de se rassembler pour défendre
des valeurs républicaines et une
certaine idée de la démocratie et de la
laïcité
donc je crois que malheureusement que ce
soit en 2015 et en 2020 ou en 1945 il ya
toujours un fond de haine parce que on
est ainsi fait qu'on n'ait pas des
animaux pacifiste mais il ya toujours
des gens bien pour combattre ça oui moi
j'y crois profondément
et d'ailleurs il ya des passages très
touchants dans le livre dans lequel vous
réagissez à des propos d'enfants qui ne
sont pas charlie dès le plus jeune âge
alors par exemple l'un d'eux attaque
votre fils avec des mots extrêmement
durs
vous allez aussi à la rencontre de dado
dans les établissements scolaires vous
venez parler du travail de votre mari et
vous êtes confrontés a justement un à
ces clivages est-ce que c'est nécessaire
crucial pour vous d'avoir les mots pour
adoucir ce clivage les clivages
religieux les clivages sociaux dans
cette perspective là surtout moi je
continue à tignes c'est à ce moment là
et c'était important d'avoir le même le
même message que lui et il nous faut
travailler énormément avec les jeunes et
il a lui était un enfant avec un
parcours scolaire difficile il était
dans les classes passerelles donc ce
existe plus les classes passerelles mais
c'est les filières techniques donc les
pas normaux il a beaucoup souffert de sa
team ou s'il disait souvent si moi
j'avais pas dessiner je serais sûrement
aux morts ou en prison et
c'était un gamin de la banlieue qui a
grandi dans une cité et donc c'était
nécessaire pour lui d'aller à la
rencontre des jeunes en leur disant mais
si vous croyez à vos rêves si vous
travaillez vous allez y arriver
et moi je voulais continuer à délivrer
cette parole là que je trouve juste et
au final même s'il ya eu des rencontres
un petit peu difficile
ç'a toujours été jolie à la fin parce
que j'y suis allé sans a priori avec
respect et vous arrivez à discuter
justement de liberté de laïcité avec ces
jeunes vous arriver vraiment communiquer
avec eux on communique vraiment je crois
que la plus belle des choses c'est l'un
d'entre eux qui pourtant au début a été
vraiment
[Musique]
mme agressé verbalement et aller au bout
d'une heure et demie de débat il est
venu me dire bon je suis toujours pas
d'accord avec vous mais c'est bien ce
que vous faites faut continuer alors il
ya un autre moyen pour vous de faire
perdurer cet esprit quelque chose qui
vous a aussi soutenu et qui a honoré la
mémoire de votre mari c'est de faire
connaître son travail au plus grand
nombre donc vous avez édité plusieurs
livres il ya maintenant une bourse un
prix à son nom une salle d'exposition
qui porte son nom et puis vous agissez
aussi derrière les états généraux du
dessin de presse
ce que vous est-ce que vous pouvez vous
parler de toutes ces initiatives alors
toutes les initiatives dont je suis très
très fier mais aussi lasalle delà du
conseil de la mairie de paris qui
s'appelle salt in youth maintenant une
vingtaine de ses dessins sont reproduits
sur les murs donc ce n'est pas des
cadres accrochés c'est des vrais
reproduction donc c'est pérenne s'est
ouvert aux journées du patrimoine pour
tous a été important parce que moi je
voulais pas être une victime
je voulais pas que tignes où ce soit une
victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à 8 e-news la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur
donc il fallait il fallait d'abord
donner à voir ce travail-là faire que
son nom fasse écho à son travail et
surtout qu'on soit et c'est notamment la
dernière démarche avec les prix qui news
et la bourse parce qu'il ya une bourse
pour un jeune artiste toujours continuer
à aider les jeunes ça c'était le credo
de tindouf et les états généraux c'est
de dire que si on ne scie on veut pas
être victimes si on veut pouvoir se
battre
concrètement et ben il faut pouvoir se
réunir pour réfléchir ensemble à demain
et pour vous il faut toujours se battre
plus que jamais mais oui oui mais voilà
moi j'ai rencontré un journaliste
politique j'ai déjà oui je crois qu'il
faut mener des combats bien sûr sans
armes
qu'est ce qui vous a soutenu aux appâts
votre force intérieure pendant toute ces
cinq années puisque vous a permis de
vous en sortir je vous répondrai
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu bateau
mais je vous dirais l'amour ce que je
crois que moi j'étais une femme très
très aimé j'ai une femme très très
amoureuse et je dans un premier temps il
ya je pouvais faire vivre l'artiste et
je voulais me venger et je voulais me
venger de manière pacifiste
donc il ya eu trois ans de travail
intense pour tignes où ce et après il y
à nos amis nos enfants dire que à un
moment donné la vie quand même revient
ce moment où moi je me suis réveillé de
de ce travail infinie autour de ti
mousse en me disant qu'est ce que je
fais moi maintenant
en tant que femme est-ce que je continue
et ce que j'ai envie j'ai répondu oui à
cette question et et je me suis rendu
compte qu'on était très entouré très
aimé que je suis aujourd'hui très aimé
qu'on a énormément d'amis qui a de très
belles choses je crois que c'est ça qui
m'a qui m'a tenu
et puis comme vous dites c'est votre
expression j'ai continué et in you saw 6
mois il fallait continuer à le faire
vivre
elf a existé de toutes les manières
possibles c'est ça qui est bien avec un
artiste c'est qu'un artiste tant qu'on
publie son travail l'artiste est vivant
autre chose
vous citez dans votre livre une autre
histoire qui fait écho à cette menace
qui a pesé sur tino cecchi et l'emporté
c'est l'histoire de votre grand-mère et
d'ailleurs vous pensez tout de suite à
votre grand mère après le décès de votre
mari car c'était une survivante des
camps elle était juive et vous dites que
vous avez la même force enfin que vous
avez hérité de sa force mentale
on sait votre exemple de vie oui à ma
grand mère m'a c'est là c'est la femme
de
de la femme de ma vie parce que elle est
revenue de l'enfer qu'elle m'a
énormément raconte et donc ça n'était
pas quelque chose de tabou à la maison
au contraire moi j'ai été élevé avec
cette idée que j'étais un maillon de ce
que mes grands parents appelaient la
chaîne d'or et qu'il ne fallait pas
oublier qu'il fallait raconter pour que
ça ne recommence pas et surtout qu'il
fallait aimer la vie parce que la vie
était précieuse et ma grand mère avait
eu cette phrase magnifique un jour où
elle m'avait dit mais tu sais moi je ne
voulais pas survivre
je voulais vivre et donc c'est pour ça
que votre livre qui est très poignant
est aussi un formidable récit de
résilience vous y montrez votre force
incroyable vous êtes à la fois détruite
éparpillés mais extrêmement compact
c'est aussi ça 7les l'histoire de ce
livre
oui et j'en suis merci de le souligner
parce que j'en suis très content que je
crois que même si c'est poignant et
émouvant et douloureux c'est ça reste
plein d'espoir et ça je crois je le dis
mais oui je suis la petite fille de mme
amie paula jeu j'étais pétri de ça
depuis toujours et je pense que ça m'a
quand même sauvé la vie quels sont vos
projets aujourd'hui claude verlhac j'ai
eu beaucoup de plaisir à écrire donc je
pense que
je vais continuer et puis je travaille
sur une troisième anthologie des dessins
de tignes hausse et je crois on
rencontre donc il va y avoir plein de
projets il arrive merci beaucoup en tout
cas d'avoir accepté notre invitation
chloé verlhac avec ce livre si tu meurs
je te tue aux éditions plon qui honore
la mémoire de votre maritime youth et
parle de votre reconstruction et qui est
une ode à la vie retrouvez nous
retrouver nos émissions également sur rt
france point tva bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]